Now that we've touched on all
of the major players in the
specific immune system, what I
thought I would do in this
video is do a summary
so it all fits
together a little bit.
So the first person or character
we got exposed to
was the B cell, which
I always do in blue.
And what made that interesting
is that every B cell has its
own specific-- or they have
membrane bound antibodies, but
for each B cell, the membrane
bound antibodies on each
specific B cell had its
own variable portion.
So this B cell-- it'll be
variable right like that.
And if I were to draw another
B cell right here, I would
draw the variable portion
a little bit different.
This is why different actual
B cells will respond to
different antigens or different
pathogens that have
entered our system.
And a B cell gets activated--
let's talk about what happens
when it gets activated or
what needs to happen.
It needs binding of the pathogen
onto one of these
membrane bound antibodies.
But that's not all.
I mean, sometimes that's all you
need, but usually you also
need to be stimulated
by a T cell.
And you might say, where's
the helper T cell
stimulate this guy?
Well, B cells were also antigen
presenting cells so
he'll suck this guy in, break
him out, and present him on an
MHC II complex.
Let's say this is an
This guy gets cut up, part of
him gets presented right here,
and then an activated helper T
cell whose variable portion of
their T cell receptor is
specific to this could come
along and activate
this character.
I'm not drawing that receptor
well, but that right there is
a helper T cell and that
is the B cell.
Now, once it's activated, it
starts differentiating-- and
it starts cloning itself and
it can either turn into
effector cells-- and this true
of B cells or T cells.
Once they get activated, they
keep cloning or they either
turn into effector cells
or memory cells.
Memory cells stick around a
lot longer so that in the
future you're going to have
many more of this
version of B cells.
So if you get the same antigen
or pathogen in the future, the
likelihood of it bumping into
this type of B cell is going
to be higher so the response
will occur faster.
The effector B cells produce--
they essentially turn into
antibody making machines.
So they'll say, gee, this
antibody bonds to this antigen
that we have in the
system now.
Let me just produce
a ton of them.
So it starts building up all of
the cellular machinery and
it starts producing antibodies
like crazy.
I want to point out one thing
that my wife pointed out to me
when I was-- she overheard me
making the last video and
she's a fellow in hematology
and a lot of hematology is
immunology.
So I definitely have
to defer to her.
She is the expert on this.
In the last video, I kind of
very hand-wavingly said, B
cells, once they get activated,
if they're the
effector B cells, they
produce antibodies.
I want to be very clear.
It is only the effector B
cells that produce the
antibodies and the common term
for them-- if someone were to
walk up to you and say, what
cells in the body are
producing antibodies?
You wouldn't be wrong if you
said effector B cells, but the
common term that people expect
to hear are plasma cells.
Plasma cells and effector B
cells are the same thing, but
normally when they say, what
happens to a B cell when it
starts producing antibodies?
They then call it
a plasma cell.
They don't call it a B cell
anymore and I want to make
that very clear because my
wife's like, well, I have
attendings that if they asked
me, what cell in the body
produces antibodies?
And if you said, B cell, they
would say, no, wrong.
It's a plasma cell-- or if you
said effector B cell, they
wouldn't be happy.
They wanted to hear
plasma cell.
This is the common term used in
immunology and apparently
rheumatology circles.
Did I just say my wife
is a hematologist?
No, no.
She's studying rheumatology.
I get confused with all the
tologies sometimes.
Anyway, that's what
the B cells do.
And these antibodies can then
go attach things and mess up
viruses and antigen-- well,
viruses or instances of
antigens and bacteria-- and
tag them for pick up by
macrophages or other types
of phagocytes.
Those were the B cells.
Then you have your T cells.
And here I'm going to talk about
T cells a little bit
differently than I had in
the last few videos.
Just to give a little bit more
of a nuance-- so there's two
types of T cells.
You'll say, hey, they are helper
T cells and cytotoxic T
cells-- and you're not wrong,
but what I'm going to do is do
a slightly different
differentiation just so that
you are familiar with these
terms. So there's
two types of T cells.
All T cells have T
cell receptors.
But they also have these other
proteins on them and some of
them have these proteins
called-- CD4 proteins and some
of them have what's
called CD8.
So this one right here
would be called a
CD8 positive T cell.
It has the CD8 proteins on it.
And this would be called
a CD4 positive T cell.
I've never used these
words before.
You're like, gee, where
are these coming from?
Now, the CD4 receptor is the
thing that wants to bind--
this is the thing that helps to
go to the MHC II complexes.
So most CD4 T cells are
helper T cells.
Most of the time-- and I want
to make it very clear--
immunology is a very-- I mean,
this field, people are
discovering things on
a regular basis.
So people are still
understanding these things and
there's all sorts of special
cases, but usually when people
talk about CD4 positive T cells,
they're talking about
helper T cells.
So this is normally going to
be a helper T cell-- or you
could call it T helper,
just like that.
Likewise, the CD8 proteins,
these are attracted
to the MHC I complex.
This is what brings them to
the cells that have the
cancer, that have expressed
antigens
on their MHC I complex.
So most of the time CD8
positive T cells are cytotoxic.
And oftentimes, before a cell
gets activated, they just
describe it as a CD4 T cell
or a CD8 cell and after it
becomes activated and starts
wanting to kill things, then
maybe you call it cytotoxic.
But this is all wordplay.
I think you get the
general idea.
But just to remember what they
do, this guy-- we just said he
wants to bond to the MHC
complex, so you have MHC
complex plus presenting
some antigen.
This is MHC I right here.
We learned in the last video,
every nucleated cell in the
body expresses an
MHC I complex.
So this is the case where
something wacky is happening
inside this cell.
Maybe a virus has infected it.
Maybe it's cancerous.
It needs to die, otherwise it's
going to keep producing
viruses if it's infected by a
virus, or otherwise it's going
to keep dividing if it's
a cancer and infect
the rest of the body.
So the CD8 kills
infected cells.
I'll just say bad cells because
I don't if you can--
cancer really isn't
an infection.
Kills bad cells-- cells that
are-- if you don't kill them,
they're going to keep producing
viruses or keep
splitting and spreading the
cancer, while T cells--
they're attracted to
professional antigen
presenting cells.
And I always do a dendritic cell
right here because those
are the best antigen
presenting cells.
And they have MHC II complexes
and it's digested some antigen
and it presents it right there
and then that activates the
helper T cell.
And then when the helper T
cell-- all of these guys, once
they're activated, they all go
into effector-- they all start
differentiating into effector
and memory cells.
An effector helper T cell
does a couple of things.
So if we're talking about a
helper T cell, it can activate
B cells and it also releases
cytokines.
Let's say this guy
gets activated.
He'll also start releasing these
chemicals, which are
really those alarm bells that
tell other people to really
get in gear-- maybe B cells and
cytotoxic T cells start
proliferating more rigorously.
Actually, part of the cytotoxic
T cell activation
can be assisted or kind of
given a boost by these
cytokines-- of so by
these alarm bells.
So this guy's the alarm ringer,
while the CD8 cells or
the cytotoxic T cells--
in their effector
mode, they kill cells.
And of course in the memory
mode, there's just a bunch of
copies of these originals around
that are ready and more
than they were originally were,
so that in the future if
something like this or something
like this occurs,
they're going to be activated
faster because they're going
to be bumped into faster.
So hopefully that clears up a
little bit and I introduced a
little bit more tough
terminology, but I really want
to stress my wife's point
because she said, hey, you
don't want people out there
saying B cells produce
antibodies even though it is
effector B cells-- activated B
cells that have differentiated
into effector B cells.
Those are what are producing
antibodies-- because when they
go to medical school, people
are going to want to hear
plasma cell.